want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get the
seven best lessons from elon musk jeff
bezos and other billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one minimize risks with jeff
bezos the heart of
entrepreneurship in some ways
is about
risk-taking
but i think that
people
many people misperceive what good
entrepreneurs do good entrepreneurs
don't like risk
they seek to reduce risk
so they are you know you kind of
starting a company is already risky and
then you systematically eliminate risk
step by step in those early days
until you can get a company you need a
lot of i mean
believe me you know you need a lot of
luck in all endeavors in life
and certainly amazon has had you know
planetary alignment of the highest order
we're you know lots of luck in our in
our history but you but you also need to
systematically try to identify risks and
then as the company gets
bigger and more robust you can start
taking risks again but in those early
days a lot of it is about okay we have a
good idea how do we reduce risk lesson
number two build good friendships with
bill gates when your mother first said
i'd like you to come and have dinner uh
with me and warren buffett will be here
you should meet him you didn't seem that
interested why was that well warren i
thought it was somebody who
bought and sold securities which is a
very zero-sum thing that's not curing
disease or a cool piece of software
and the idea of you know kind of looking
at volume curves and
it doesn't
invent anything and so i thought my way
of looking at the world what i wanted to
figure out and do and what he looked at
that there wouldn't be much intersection
and that's why it was so shocking when i
met him
he was the first person to really ask me
about software and software pricing and
why wasn't ibm with all of their
strength able to overwhelm microsoft and
what what was going to happen in terms
of how software would change the world
and
you know he let me ask him about okay
well why do you invest in certain
industries and why are some banks more
profit than others and he was clearly a
broad systems thinker and so it started
a conversation
that
has been fun and enriching and uh you
know an incredible friendship that was
completely unexpected lesson number
three disrupt with purpose with elon
musk that's all my goal is not
disruption for the sake of instruction
um i i really
think there's okay there's some
important things we have to solve in
order for the future to be good yeah i
would say like my you know
my sort of algorithm or optimization is
like okay what set of things do we need
to do
uh to ensure that the
increase the probability of the future
is going to be good yeah and so if we if
we have to solve sustainable energy yeah
this is total logical if we do not solve
sustainable energy then we have
unsustainable energy then it's just a
matter of time before things go before
civilization collapses we must but even
beside even if there was not an
environmental issue
since the
availability of oil is limited yeah uh
this is not something we can sustain
long term yeah my original interest in
electric vehicles was actually not
environmental it was out of concern just
you know studying physics and i'm like
wait a second yeah we we immediately
transitioned to uh solar electric yeah
uh or we're gonna have a problem and and
we run out of oil civilization collapses
that's a problem now of course the
environmental concerns uh have
added to the uh urgency um
because the the more uh co2 co2 we put
in the oceans and atmosphere the more we
increase the probability that uh
something will go wrong
like i said like things are much more
probability as opposed to certainty uh
but i think it's an unwise experiment to
dramatically increase the co2 yeah in
the atmosphere and oceans yeah just
given that we know we need to transition
anyway because we ran out of oil yeah so
why run that experiment it's not it
doesn't make any sense um we know we
have to transition to a sustainable
energy economy
um then let's just get on with it yeah
you know let's just get on with it and
not run the crazy experiment and see if
the what happens if the atmosphere has
2000 ppm
co2 this is crazy
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
lesson number four be consistent with
oprah winfrey we
all are here to fulfill the dreams of
those who came before us
maya used to say you've been paid for
you've been paid for young people so put
your crown on your head and wear it
we are here not merely to bear witness
but to be the new voices of an
extraordinary
new age you see when i was growing up
there were no black people in the media
just buckwheat
on television
and i was constantly doing that thing
looking to find myself and what i found
and said was leave it to beaver and
donna reed and lassie although
technically i guess lassie was mostly
brown the the point is though we are now
able to see ourselves reflected through
entertainment but what pleases me most
is that we're beginning to see
on screen
what we're beginning to see is starting
to change the landscape of what we see
behind the scenes what kamal was talking
about true inclusion and what i realized
during all those years during the oprah
show and the reason that own is now
thriving is how essential it is to see
yourself reflected in other people's
stories it's something that you as white
people never have to even think about
because the more you see a broader and
richer and more nuanced depiction of
yourself and your neighbor and the world
the more empowered you become and it's
that sense of empowerment that actually
tethers us to the universe it gives us
at least a glimpse of how connected we
all are
so what a blessed sign of progress it is
to know that millions of kids in 2019
don't have to stand with their noses
pressed up against the window or the
television screens looking in at a
family that makes them feel less than by
comparison today we can point to work
that says you are every bit as valued
and vital to the fabric of life as
anyone else you are a part of a
community but it takes time it takes
time to see yourself it takes time to
hear yourself and to feel to feel
appreciated for just being yourself
empowerment does not happen overnight
like change
it is never just one thing it is a
series of consistent steps great and
small that proves to us again and again
that genuine change is actually possible
lesson number five don't limit yourself
with mark cuban you know
there's there's no we live in a day and
age where you can start anything do
anything and
you you shouldn't put limits on yourself
i think everybody's here because they
don't believe there are limits on
themselves and that they can get out
there and do anything and i like to
point to myself look if i can do it
there's a lot more people out there that
can do it and you guys should never let
anything hold you back lesson number six
follow your beliefs with vinod khosla i
am amazed at how few people have a
belief system what do they actually
believe in
um
i
and and yeah it's okay to offend you
guys
90 of you will do what's expected of you
as opposed to what you want to do
and
you know i even when i come to an event
like this say why am i here why would i
even bother to take an hour of my
valuable time
no it's true i i have to have a purpose
my goal is very simple if i can convert
one of you
there's probably 400 500 people here if
i can convert one of you to follow your
belief and have the guts to follow your
belief
all have
i'll think of the hour as well spent
but
so i always say what am i trying to do
and why i don't speak because somebody
you know will write nice things about it
i always sort of have a purpose but i
have a belief system
and
most people even successful companies
and have big beef with fortune 500 ceos
i can talk about
there's very little leadership there
uh don't have an internal compass of
what they believe in
it's what do others expect
you know when i graduated i went into
entrepreneurship
nobody went into entrepreneurship out of
the business school and people said why
wouldn't you work
for goldman or mckinsey and i said why
would you
like i couldn't fathom why you would
want to
do that job
right
i still can't by the way
for those of you going to those places
i'm sure there's plenty i'm probably not
the right person to talk to you
i frankly don't even care to talk to you
all of you others
i i think there's something wrong with
anybody who fundamentally wants to go
work for one of the consultants or the
investment banks today in this part
they don't understand how the world is
going to work in the future
but my point again is have a belief
system follow that compass
and i'm overstating it a bit so
there may be some hope for those of you
going there
but
it's only a little bit of an
exaggeration
let me go back to this issue of fortune
500 ceos
i've talked to many over the years
if a new york times writer writes an
article
they want to change their strategy they
want to respond
how silly is that that some english
major who's never had a business job can
determine the strategy of a fortune 500
company
why because they care about what's
written not what their belief system is
do you know what elon musk would say to
that writer go get a real job right
what jeff bezos would say that's
leadership having a belief system
knowing what's driving you to do what
you do
not you're fitting in to do career
enhancement
or
making it look good to somebody else
whether it's to your friends or to your
boss or to
shareholders
and frankly
you look at all the companies that are
languishing in the valley the older
companies
they generally don't have a belief
system they're generally trying to meet
some quarterly target without saying
here's how we will be different and
here's how we'll do it apple did
languish for 10 15 years and then steve
jobs came in with a point of view and
created the most valuable company in the
world he did irrational things if you go
back to january of 2000 2007
january 1
everybody was saying nobody wants a
phone without a keyboard
nobody wants a phone that costs 6.99 i
can go on with the litany
those were all english majors writing
articles i have this beef against
english majors
not all english majors are bad but the
majority of them at stanford are
undirected and don't have a goal or a
purpose
sorry uh
and that's not to say among them there
isn't 20 that are really good they just
didn't get the right guidance and ended
up in the wrong place
i like purposeful education and lesson
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is double down
on what works with grant cardone right
now in 2020 here we are in april right
we have this covida thing happen and we
have massive unemployment worldwide
literally a worldwide recession if not a
depression about it
in formation right now
this is not the time for me to go try
something new
this is the time for me to double down
on what's working how to help people
right now how do i scale cardone
university how do i help customers i
need to actually contract a second
so that i could pull the forces back
and
prepare for another assault yeah you
can't just go run out like a lot of
people think 10x is oh all the time
you're 10x sometimes 10x means i got to
contract again get rid of some stuff so
i can double down or 10x on the things
that are working so i can move again
and set up that other company that i
want uh to
for instance the real estate i can't go
expand my real estate portfolio in this
environment today
not because i don't want to but because
the markets have seized up
i need a second
i need a second for things to relieve
themselves
uh to to
in order to go back and go from 7 000
units to 14 000 units
at what point was it where you guys said
huh you know what we might be on to
something here with these paul mitchells
you know shampoo and conditioners which
you guys came to be known for what was
the point where you guys said hmm like
let's do this like what was the well we
were planning to do it because i knew
the business
i was in marketing sales and structure
and had connections with uh product
development
and i didn't do hair
paul was a great hairdresser one of the
best in the world very advanced in what
he did however he didn't do business it
was the perfect combination these two
guys together we're just the best of
friends and we knew we could do it uh
obviously we started out with nothing we
made the decision let's just let's just
make this happen and as you will see in
your guests we'll see when they look at
good fortune the movie and it's on
itunes it's on amazon all those when
they look at it it's the whole story of
starting in america with nothing a
couple times and making things happen
because of what you believe in but the
important thing is even we had nothing
we started giving back whether it was
the first company to say we will never
test on animals and never have to this
state wow or other things we do not
shake your hand today sure you betcha
but i'll applaud you that's awesome it's
still going on that one i have had
before co-partners in some businesses
i've tried and not as good as my partner
paul mitchell but in other businesses
and they didn't turn out to be what i
thought they would be so if you have a
partner
one you've got to be friendly to one
another you also have to have your
boundaries where okay i live my life you
live your life we can't live it all
together we're together we have a
certain goal now if you do have i call
it a challenge opposed to a problem
the best way to address it is not do it
for example aggressively
don't attack on it instead it's much
easier to say
well you know liz uh you're you're a
wonderful person we've done some really
great business together but with all due
respect when i came in here i had a
great idea i wanted to tell you and you
kept on cutting me off and it made me
feel bad liz you know as well that just
made me feel bad and i know you'd like
to hear it i just wanted to share that
with you you share your feelings with
the person if they have an idea you
don't think it's any good you could say
you know that's
that that's a great idea i could
appreciate where you're coming from
always validate the person however can
we look at this a little differently
maybe we can enhance it and build upon
it and you come in with your two cents
always respect the other person
the biggest impact a company can have is
staying within its area of expertise
so
you know to make sure that
the education systems around the world
that they get good software and we have
a donation program where we've done
called it's called partners and learning
we have deals with 132 countries how we
grant them software and fund teacher
training in each of those countries so
microsoft's main thing will be about
that library access that school access
the free software the training you know
the job skills and the partners that are
in that
uh country
uh not
not
not so much health care and
whereas the big drug companies we need
to get them into the health care issues
and the banks we need to get into
microfinance and the food companies we
need to get into micronutrients and
buying the output of the farmers in
these poor countries so that the their
economies get going so i think
everybody's got a big role to play
but it's it's going to be fairly
centered on the thing that that the
employees know and
drives their their specific contribution
i remember one great fear i had
when we did microsoft research was that
they
if we weren't careful it'd be
a block to our view of what was going on
in the academic community that is we
would hire somebody
who had an approach
and that academia as a whole would have
like 20 approaches you know a number of
which would likely be better than some
internal approach and so i wanted
somebody who was open-minded enough to
say no the you know this group here
uh is doing it the right way uh and i
was worried would that fluidity exist so
a lot of these programs like having
students come here like the faculty
summit have contributed to the idea that
okay we're part of a broader committee
community
we publish great things you know people
come and go
a lot so i feel super good about that
in terms of work uh
you know i would say the most of the
opportunity to make computers improve
work is in front of us instead of behind
us
only at kind of a very mechanical level
of
uh it's better than whiteout
you know are we like oh wow this thing
helps me get my work done
for extremely structured tasks like
creating financial statements you know
where the application logic is very
opaque and you're just led through it or
for very horizontal things where you
really understand what you're up to and
the machine doesn't see
oh that email is part of personnel
review that email is part of planning
the uh the sales force meeting so we
have kind of the the low-level
horizontal which in this way is
amazing and then we have this very
structured applications world
the idea of of
matching
what you and your head have is the
intention of the overall activity and
the semantics around it
and therefore sort of maximally helping
you with those things i think now
uh that a lot of base level things are
are done very well including gathering
the data and learning from it that we
should be able to
have what the machine thinks you're up
to and what you think you're up to match
each other
and
improve the productivity quality quality
quite dramatically you can't get what
you want by focusing on what you don't
want
this is about the need to
establish as many meaningful connections
as we can
if we're going to save the world we have
to find a way to connect to each other
to connect to the nature that we're
killing to animals to history to an
acknowledgement of the lingering trauma
of racism and sexism we need to connect
to the people we love and mean something
to us and more than that to the people
who don't
that doesn't mean we always have to
agree with another person's philosophy
it means
we if we're going to continue to survive
and thrive on this planet have to find
ways to transcend the politics of
division and embrace the places that
bond us where we find our human ground
everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams
there is
there was a time
where i used to spend a lot of energy
wanting things
wanting things
of course it's easy for me to say oh
things don't define you because i got a
lot of things things nice i like them
but this is what i learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space
that you purposefully have come to earth
to claim for yourself so
around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning
uh sunday morning should have been in
church but i wouldn't
i was reading
the new york times review of the color
purple
and i thought whoa this sounds like a
really great book i got out of bed in my
pajamas put on my galoshes
and
went to the store to get the copy of the
color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple i took the
books to to the office and i said to
everybody y'all got to read this book oh
my god you got to read this book color
purple i needed a book club i didn't
have one
so i passed out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear
that somebody's gonna do a movie about
the color purple but i don't know
anybody in the movie business by this
time i was on am chicago i don't know
anybody i start praying to god god
please help me find a way to get into
color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as
as
divine law would have it quincy jones
comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one half of a
day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson claiming that
billie jean was their lover and that's
not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower
and the television in his hotel room is
on am chicago
there sits little chubby me
with my jarrett curl
on am chicago
quincy jones tells ruben cannon the
casting agent i think i found
sophia so i get a call
for movement cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song
would you be interested to come and
audition and i say i have not been
praying for moon song
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well
i think you should come and and audition
so i go to audition you know movie
people they make everything all secret
steven spielberg didn't want anybody
know he was doing color purple so on the
outside of the script it says moon song
but i know all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus this is the color
purple
yes
[Applause]
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie oh that i'm
thinking prayer prayer works
prayer works
but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february
march
april may comes i haven't heard anything
so i call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon
i'm sorry sir i haven't heard anything i
expected to hear something by now and
reuben cannon
african-american man
says to me
you don't call me
i call you
and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying
i can't believe that god has played this
trick on me i think
this is a trick
so i decide that this is because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose
25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i i also
was trying to make peace with it
i said god
i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says real actresses
have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track
at the fat farm
it starts to rain y'all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life i start praying
running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i i
can't there's nobody on the track but me
and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
there's nobody on the truck so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me
help me let it go help me let it go help
me let it go god help me let it go
and you ever did this prayer where you
say okay lord don't come and let it go
then you get up and you go well i think
i still got a little bit of it
i did help me let it go
but i am not going to be able to see the
other actress
in my part i won't be able to see it i
won't be able to see color purple just
can't ever see it the rest of my life i
won't be able to see it
so then i started
i don't know where it came from
i surrender all
i
surrender all
to thee my
blessed
savior
i
surrender all
i sang and i cried
i sang and i cried and i prayed some
more
until
i could reach the point where not only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress
i can bless her
i can say
i bless you i bless you i bless you with
this i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee
my
blessed savior
i
surrender all and i tell you
in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me anymore
it had no control over me anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power that was greater than i could
ever know the instant that happened
a woman comes running out of the
cafeteria
screaming oh free
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody can pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's saying named
spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound
you could lose this part
[Applause]
no
problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said you're
hired you're hired first of all
you don't need college learning learn
stuff okay
everything is available basically for
free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning
um
there is
a value that colleges have which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's
is can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of
sort of annoying homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh and and kind of soldier through and
get it done
you know that's
that's like
the main value of college and then also
you know if you if you probably want to
hang around with a bunch of people your
own age for a while instead of going
right into the workforce
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning the real
way i think you you actually achieve
intellectual property protection is by
innovating fast enough if your rate of
innovation is high
then you don't need to worry about
protecting vip
because
other companies will be copying
something that you did years ago
and that's fine you know
just make sure
your rate of innovation is fast um
speed is really speed of innovation is
what is what matters
um
and i do i do say this to my teams like
quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go innovation per year if you
want to say like is is what matters not
innovation
absent time because if you wanted to
make say
um 100 improvement in something
and that took 100 years or one year
that's
radically different
so
um it's like what is your rate of
innovation
that that that matters and is the rate
of innovation
um
is that accelerating or decelerating
and a weird thing happens when companies
get big is that most companies
or organizations the bigger they get
they tend to
get less innovative
not just less innovative on a per person
basis but less innovative in the
absolute
um
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
uh
is not
there for innovation
it's not enough to use words to
encourage innovation the incentive
structure must be aligned with that
that's fundamental i haven't had any
existential crisis knock on wood i find
i don't want to jinx anything
um
but we've had a lot of uh
kind of
dramatic events i remember
early on
we only had 125 employees when barnes
and noble who the big united states
bookseller
opened their online website to compete
against us barnesandnoble.com we'd had
about a two-year window we opened in 95
they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be destroyed by this much
larger company we had 125 employees
and
60 million dollars a year in annual
sales 60 million with an m
and that uh and barnes noble at the time
had 30 000 employees
and about 3 billion dollars in sales
so
they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were um very negative about
amazon and the one that's most minimal
or memorable was just amazon.toast
and um
and so i called an all hands meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people and we got in a room and because
it was so um scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor
that literally everybody's parents were
calling and saying you know are you okay
it's usually the moms um
calling and asking their children are
you gonna be okay so and i said look you
know it it's okay to be afraid um but
don't be afraid of our competitors
because they're never going to send us
any money be afraid of our customers and
if we just stay focused on them in in in
in instead of
obsessing over this big competitor that
we just got
that we'll be fine and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is
the the what your response to it should
be to double down on the customer
satisfying them not just satisfying them
delighting them we're very interested in
physical stores and we haven't i've been
asked for years
we ever opened physical stores literally
20 years have been asked the question
and i always say yes but only when we
have
a differentiated
differentiated offering something that's
not me too
because that space physical storage is
so well served if we offer a metoo
product offering it's not gonna work
we're and it's also just we're not very
good at that most of the whenever we've
tried
dabbling in something that's a me too
service we tend to get
beaten it doesn't work we're
our culture is much better at pioneering
and inventing and so we have to have
something that's different and that's
what amazon go is it's completely
different the amazon bookstore
completely different and we have ideas
about how to merge prime and whole foods
to make that
those are still rolling out you haven't
seen them yet but to make to use amazon
prime to make whole foods a very
differentiated experience and so what
we're going to be able to do is take
some of our resources some of our
technical technological know-how and and
expand the whole foods mission
they have a great mission which is to
bring nourishing food to everybody
organic nourishing food to everybody and
but you know we have a lot to bring to
that table in terms of resources but
also in terms of operational excellence
and in terms of technology know-how we
are not a company that
normally china caller we call ourselves
a company running a platform a company
that is running an ecosystem
we are almost everywhere people say jack
you know you are in the b2b and b2c and
you're calling c2b on a finance and
online payment logistics cloud computing
you are everywhere
not because we are greeted not because
we want to do it because we have to do
it if we cannot if we do not do it china
e-commerce in the years will collapse
i remember nine years ago when i started
the alipay people say jack don't touch
the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison
and i we taught ourselves if we don't do
it
the china e-commerce were always like a
like a chat
room everybody said it's a good thing
and yeah i don't pay you don't get the
things so i say well put me in the
prison let's make sure that alipay the
payment solution works
and people say the payment solution is
such a stupid idea it's an escrow
service
i pay you hold the money and you get the
things
you pay the money if you don't get the
things you want return the money they
said it's a stupid product
and i say as long as they solve the
problem i like stupid things you know
let's make stupid things smart keep on
improving every day i never thought it
would be successful i never thought
we could survive for 18 years
and then we made it
the only thing that today we should do
is share the experience and know how
especially share the mistakes
suffer with others
my
thinking is that
you guys remember
if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
successful stories they make
don't listen to that
there are a lot of reasons behind it
just like um
i remember the first time harvard
business school came to us say jack
we want to write a
case study for you
yes yes 2001 or 2000.
they came they spent one week and they
write a report and i read no no i said
this is not me
and this is this is you that's no this
is not us he said this is you so the
makeup is sign
and the case study go up and they start
to teach in a lot of universities the
next five years they invited me to go to
the case study and they always find a
competitor of my company and if after
every
case study alibaba will die that company
will succeed
all the students agree and
actually every five years all the
competitors die we still survive
so how can you study this kind of a
successful story
learn from the mistakes the other people
no matter how smart you are you will
encounter these mistakes you learn from
mistakes not because you will be able to
avoid mistakes you were able to when
these mistakes come this suffer comes
you know how to deal with it
how to face it
i
i the book i want to write
if i
if i want
if i can
it's alibaba 1 000 one mistake you
haven't bought the stock you're an
admirer of jeff bezos a listing of the
richest people in america came out he's
number one i think your friend bill
gates is number two you're number three
so you can see what he's done in myriad
ways
and of course the question is
how come you haven't bought amazon is
there still time to buy would you still
buy it oh i i always admired
jeff i mean i met him 20 years ago or so
and and
and
i thought he was something special but i
didn't realize you could go from books
to what what's happened there no i i
mean he had a vision
and executed in an incredible way
something that
it would not have
you know that
but there's a lot of games i miss i
would have missed you know i would have
missed microsoft even if i got into no
bill
earlier or something those just aren't
my games i don't worry about the things
that i miss that are outside my circle
of confidence
of evaluating i i do i have missed
things that were within my circle
and that's a terrible mistake those are
my biggest mistakes you haven't seen
them and but i don't
it's not a mistake because i miss
netscape or something like that at all
i would say that maybe five percent of
the companies or ten percent of the
companies at most are within an area my
circle of confidence there's something i
should be able to understand if you buy
a business if you buy a farm you know do
you go up and look
you know every couple weeks to see how
far the corn is up and you know you
worry too much about whether somebody
says this is going to be a year of low
prices because exports are being
affected or anything like that you know
you buy a farm and you hold it for i've
got one farm that i bought in the 1980s
and my son runs it but
i've been there once you know i mean it
it it doesn't grow faster if i go and
stare at it you know i can't cheer for
it you know more effort more effort or
something like that and i know there's
going to be some years when prices are
going to be good and some when the
prices aren't going to be good i know
there's years when yields will be better
than others
but about the farm and and uh
if
it just doesn't i don't care about
economic predictions on everything of
the sort i do care that over
over the years it's well tended to in
terms of rotating crops and i hope
yields get better which they generally
have
in fact
that farm
100 years ago would have probably
produced
30 bushels maybe 35 bushels of corn per
acre
now in a good year you know it'd be 200
i mean we really made progress in this
country that's one reason commodity
prices go back a couple hundred years
they've moved so little is because we've
just gotten better and better at
whether it's
cotton or whether it's it's corn or
soybeans or
all kinds of things and you and i have
benefited from that
and so apple's kind of like a farm
well it's it's a it's a long term
investment and and
if you owned
if you own the the best auto dealership
in town the best brand and had
somebody
good running he wouldn't drop by every
day and say you know how many people
have come in today or you know i think
interest rates are going up a little
maybe that'll slow down our sales or
anything no
you buy it knowing there's 365 days a
year and you're going to own it for 20
years so that's 7 300 days and you know
they're gonna things are going to be
different from day to day and year to
year you shouldn't buy it at the
day-to-day stuff so how have you hired
your team uh and what do you look for
when you bring people on
if you think about it
you know i started the company when i
was 19 right so
i can't institutionally believe that
experience is that important right or
else i would have a hard time
reconciling um you know myself right and
and and the company so you know we
invest in
in people who we think are just really
talented even if they haven't done that
thing before and you know that applies
to people who are fresh out of
university as well as
you know people like um you know the cfo
who took the company public had not
taken a company public before right and
a lot of his background was in um you
know production uh development at
genentech before so you know just focus
on really talented people when you first
launched in the very beginning the
features were sort of profile with like
a profile photo in your name and who you
are and also you included things like
what house you lived in um what dorm you
lived in um and what courses you were
taking
do you think it would have worked
without that would it have been enough
just to have profiles
you know it's a really interesting
question and we certainly since then
have evolved and wanted to make a more
general service so we've so we've
dropped some of those things
but i remember there's this early
debate that dustin and i had where
we had to do some manual work for every
school that we that we released facebook
at and um in order to do that we
basically went through and we parsed the
course catalogs of the schools to make
sure that the data was clean
and um and i remember having this debate
where dustin was like we could just
expand so much faster
or it would just be easier i mean we
were bound by server capacity but it
would be easier to launch new schools
if we didn't have to have course
catalogs for for each school and we just
had this really long debate
about what quality meant for us and the
the community that we wanted to
establish and and the culture of it and
um you know in retrospect you know maybe
you wouldn't have had a huge difference
on on how things played out but it
definitely kind of set this tone where
there's a lot of kind of clean data on
facebook you can rely on it it feels
like a college specific thing yeah which
was valuable early on for setting the
culture even though obviously since then
we've grown beyond that and you know i
mean i think you guys in the projects
that you work on you're gonna have a lot
of similar questions right i mean
there's the famous 80 20 rule where you
know you get 80 of the benefit by doing
20 of the work uh but
you can't just 80 20 everything right i
mean there have to be certain things
that you just are the best at right and
that you go way further than anyone else
had to establish this kind of quality
bar and have your product be the best
thing that's out there so you know
whether we had to do that one or had to
do something we had to do i think enough
of those things or else we just wouldn't
have been the best service out there
what keeps you so unbelievably grounded
amid all your resounding success
i i feel like success just makes you
more of who you already were i feel like
money and success just does that so
it's like it holds a magnifying glass up
to who you are people you know people
always ask me that and i'm like i don't
know who else to be i mean i am who i am
so the money the success
and um so i like to say if you were a
jerk before you got really successful
and a lot of money you you become a
bigger jerk usually and if you were
insecure you'll become more insecure if
you were nice you'd become nicer if you
were generous you'll become more
generous it's literally just
a magnifying glass what is it about
selling the that you actually enjoyed
that you think most people most people
don't enjoy selling so what is it about
selling that you actually well okay this
is the first thing i'm going to say if
you don't like selling
you should really take the time for
yourself to practice it and learn it
because all of life is sales i mean
whether you're an accountant whether
you're a stay-at-home mother and you're
trying to sell your kids on why they
need to go to bed at a certain time or
they need to do something that you need
them to do in an interview you have to
sell yourself i mean and so um i think
it's really important to be able to to
do that and and hardcore door-to-door
sales was incredible groundwork and laid
that laid the foundation for me to be
able to do spanx because when i started
spanx the first two years that i was
cold calling all the manufacturers in
north carolina i only heard one word
no yeah
i mean no no no and because i had
training and just knew i'm going to keep
going until i get that yes that's the
reason that i was able to get through
that stage
there's nothing that ai won't impact as
big as the so bit having been around a
while i saw the impact of pcs then i saw
the impact of local area networks then i
saw the impact of wide area networks
then i saw the impact of the internet
then i saw the impact of mobile then i
saw the impact of wireless you know now
i'm seeing the impact of of artificial
intelligence and it dwarfs any of those
things and if i don't understand how to
apply it to my businesses i mean i
remember selling pcs and software and
walking in saying you don't need to use
that pen and paper on on a you know on a
notepad or a ledger pad now we're going
to give you a spreadsheet and by the way
here's a here's a spreadsheet that costs
495 and i had to pay to go get trained
on how to sell it which is crazy now
when you think about it but then we said
okay now you can play what if then we
said you can connect these pcs unless i
understood the technology how was i
going to explain it how was i going to
understand it unless i understand it now
how am i going to invest in it
you know then i got to go trust somebody
who says oh yeah i know ai and maybe
they do maybe they don't and it's really
easy just to have just the okay so you
figure it out that's just not my style
so you're building a base of knowledge
and then you think that at some point
it's going to pay dividends and trades
already has right i mean if you truly
believe ai is going to change everything
how are you going to understand what
people are doing to change everything
unless you at least have a foundational
understanding of it now i'm not going to
build a million layer neural network and
try to change the world and i'm not
going to show you i'm not going to write
a research paper and saying here's how
why the lottery ticket approach works
and you can build smaller neural
networks with less data um and be more
you know
resource efficient but i can read that
stuff and understand that when somebody
says okay we're building this project
and we need this size data center this
size data set we need this amount of
resources i can ask questions and
understand the answers the same thing i
told myself the same thing i tell
everybody
one you're 21 22 23 years old right you
don't have to figure it out right now
don't try
right you spend all this money
sorry
um
paying to learn now it's your chance to
get paid to learn
you don't need the perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn
and start to be exposed to different
ideas and now it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago
you know it was like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for ibm or general motors
and get a pension those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore
and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
kevin durants and lebron james you know
where you're always out there and can go
find a better situation for yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
umeki um
um
you know what how bad could it be i
would lose my motel 6 towel you know
it was just like what have you got to
lose and yeah i understand there's
pressure from student loans and there's
a lot of conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect you can
learn at that job and you guys have the
pedigree you have the brains you have
the initiative to go out and try the
next job you know
you know the good news is the economy is
good enough that it may not be perfect
but you can go job to job don't look for
the perfect answer just look to get the
experience look to learn because all
these different exposures all the
different things you learn learning how
to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juicy for for something that
you love because once you find something
you love to do
that's when the magic happens because
when you're when you're able to find
something you love to do then you can
start work focusing on how can i be
great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know play with
technology and try to do things first
you know whatever it is that you find
about yourself then you can try to be
great at it and it's rare when people
quit things they're great at
you know and so trying those things so
that that's how i advise people don't
don't stress just go out and try
different things the thing i think that
i did right from the beginning um and
even
now in this moment uh now that my
circumstances are very different is i've
i've always known and this comes from i
think my faith deep down inside i've
always known that like what i'm called
to do isn't about me
and so
for me it's it's what's fueled me
in all the times
when it seemed like no one else believed
in me like i knew why i was doing this
um was so much bigger than myself and to
really shift culture and beauty and even
now
even just saying like oh my gosh
you started something in your living
room and someone pays you a billion
dollars for it like if i think about
that i can't even process it right
i can't even handle it because what
happens is i'll start thinking of like
oh but you know
i don't i didn't come from the right
family no one of my neither my parents
went to college all those things that we
tell ourselves about why
we're not the person that has those kind
of things happening to us um
and so so two things one i i often
remind myself that like anything that's
ever been created that's great or that's
a brand we all use now or a big business
like it was all created by somebody
really at the end of the day who's just
like you and me just like all of us
every single thing right so like why not
i'm not you why not yeah and then and
then the other thing is like when i
really start to um
kind of like get in my own head about it
because it is really
strange you see like oh yeah like
all those things like um i i make it not
about my i i know i remind myself it's
it's not about me right so for my book
for example i'm donating 100 of the
proceeds but like like i the the book is
to serve right and like i i believe at
the end of the day that we get in life
like what we give you know what i mean
along this whole journey i've known it's
bigger than myself even now like i just
i don't know i believe that you know i'm
called to serve and and to
like i feel blessed to have accomplished
one of my biggest dreams but my my
biggest
my biggest driver now is helping other
women
um
and especially their entrepreneurs and
really other women like accomplish their
greatest dreams this depression thing
yeah like this this is a topic that
interests me so much have you ever dealt
with it at all totally okay almost my
whole life still a little bit uh
no well what happens is socially we say
it's depression
but what if
okay what if
it wasn't depression and it was just
truth
that i'm having to sleep with my own
truth that i can do more
right so why wouldn't i be
a bit depressed
if i have this potential and i'm
operating here every individual knows
what they're capable of
right so if i know i have this much
potential
and i'm living here
wouldn't i be like a little bit
disappointed with myself
now where did where what happened where
because back in the 50s
there was no depression nobody was
talking about depression people were
talking about how do i get to the next
level right today in our in our
psychiatric community where where drugs
are where the average american has eight
prescriptions sitting in their medicine
cabinet
like i'm on one drug i got to take a
second drug to handle the third drug
because of the blood pressure drug
because of this drug and dude i'm
stacking out like
why
because i was depressed why am i
depressed
because i don't look like
i don't have his arms
i have the potential to have his arms
maybe not
pretty close but but but it would
require me to go to work right or or i
need to look a different way or i'm i'm
aging or whatever the deal is right like
so for me i have always struggled with
depression but it was more because
people were telling me i was depressed
when the truth is i was just
disappointed man me too i was
disappointed with me me too you know my
mom my mom would always tell me my mom
was always the first person i would call
any time i scored
and she was my best friend
and and she passed when when about nine
years ago when sabrina was born five
days later sabrina was born and um
every score i had i was 51 years old man
between 25 and 51 every score i had my
mom was the first person i called mom i
did this every time she had the same
response
son that's great but i love you just the
way you are
over and over she told me that and then
one day i'm like
but i don't
now i can't really say that a whole
bunch of people are going to say why
don't you love you just the way you are
something wrong with you because there's
that whole culture out there this this
uh i don't know what the term is but
it's a um
this this this holistic idea that you
should love yourself the way you are i
would tell everybody dude if you know
that you can do more do not love who you
are
achieve who you can be
because you can be more
he's done it
i've done it
and and i did it by by by replacing the
depression concept not doing the drugs
by the way i was put on him like five or
six times
and threw him away and just said you
know what i'm going to go for my goals
i'm going to go for the thing my
potential if i'm going to screw this up
i'm gonna i'm going to screw it up
grant's way not that way
the idea here is look commit
okay and this is the problem with the
schooling system everything's got to be
figured out first i got to read the
instruction first like nobody really
does read this i never read this i wrote
an article about it i don't read any
instructions you know and so
i mean i can't i can't read them because
they're so small
so so uh and even when i could read them
i'm like i don't want to read the
instructions can't they make this
simpler yeah so and that is the premise
there yeah can't it just be simpler
and and the way to make it simple is and
we see this happening today i mean this
is happening on a global scale where
picking a car up now is simple
pick me up
it's crazy i don't have to put the
address in it should locate where i am
car picks me up i put in the destination
tells guy where to go you don't even
need to pay for it either it's already i
don't have to set up like simple you
guys got everything should be simplified
and the way to simplify things i
remember mercedes benz years ago i heard
about this when they had first figured
out how to put a drop back a hard top
uh convertible into the trunk they had
never they couldn't figure it out it
used to be these old you know they'd
hang them up in the garage and take them
off and it was like very laborious
and somebody at mercedes-benz said
don't tell me what it's going to cost
tell me when it's done
just get it done no matter what this is
how the elon musk are thinking today you
know this is why apple keeps creating a
crazy product while this will go away
somebody's going to come along one day
and say get rid of the phone
and i still want to communicate yeah and
it'll probably be on a headset more like
this we'll probably we'll probably go in
here right where i'm probably i mean the
watches yeah they're they're they're
moving there right it's crazy
so to where i don't even need a watch i
won't need anything it's like okay i
want to call baba bye we're moving in
that direction of less and faster and
simpler so the way the human being does
that he's in brisbane this part of the
gold coast
i got to get down there he's committed
he doesn't figure he he just gets a
flight
no research
no no you weren't researching it last
night no not at all if you didn't
if you didn't know about this last night
you'd have been you'd have been doing
work about it last night planning
negotiating with the airlines when you
get compressed on time and you've got a
commitment you're like i got to be there
at 2 30. everything works out
yeah as i was walking out my assistant
she goes oh where where are you going to
stay
and i was like
book me a place where close to you know
to the park or where you're staying
but um we're on this trip we went to
tokyo because things don't work out as
planned anyway yeah so i'm not saying go
through life unplanned i have 500
employees so there's got to be some
planning there's got to be is that
stretched over europe it doesn't need to
be me doing the planning though yeah
like i think maybe i need somebody else
to do that i don't have to do that no i
just need to know where i want to go so
we were coming to sydney i knew i had
this commitment with success resources
to come here and do these events good
tell me when the events are bang bang
bang
um okay i got to get there right so a
week ago i'm like okay hey lanny i
called my pilot i want to let route to
sydney but
let's stop in hawaii
uh let's go to kauai
uh kids have never been there we'll stay
there for three days acclimate for a
second and shoot down to sydney i had
enough data to know that i would need to
do a route like that storm comes in
i can't get i can't for some reason i
can't get uh the place i want in kauai
storm comes across the south the pacific
and
uh lanny said hey we might want to be
careful with this storm coming down
there i said okay well let me just let's
reroute to fiji double storm pops up
double-headed cyclone
okay in our path he's like grant we
can't go that way we'd have to go all
the way around this storm i said no we
don't go to tokyo
now the point of that story is look just
keep moving forward keep moving in a
direction that you want to go to we go
to tokyo i made all these friends in
tokyo i would have never done that but i
was committed to going to sydney
and so again commit move in the
direction that gets you closer to where
you're going to go
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more amazing lessons from
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you should just be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said i was just going to be myself i
find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm quite grumpy
[Music]